hello everyone here on free code cam my
name is Anya Cuba and I'm a software
developer as well as course creator here
on freecocamp as well as on my own
channel today I will be your guide into
building a chat GPT clone the easy way
thanks to a local solution called retour
as well as an API from the actual
company that made chat gbt so in other
words we're going to be using
Microsoft's open AI API what we're going
to do is build a dashboard which will
use chat GPT to generate regex for you
so essentially a dashboard that will
generate the regex we need when writing
code regex or in other words a regular
expression is a string of text that lets
you create patterns that help match
locate and manage text we have different
characters that will do different things
so for example these characters when
applied to a string of text will take
the string remove all the numbers from
it and return the string without any
numbers present when mastered properly
we can use it to match email addresses
search and replace characters in large
texts and is even used in scraping data
however mastering writing regex is a
skirt itself wouldn't it be useful if we
just tell an app what regex to create
well that's what we're gonna do thanks
to our app that we're going to build
using the chat GPT API and retort so I
can write remove all numbers from a
sentence and it will generate the regex
for me so this as well as the code for
transforming a string we can even add a
test string so I can go ahead and write
I have two cats then run the code and
receive the result ta-da what is a great
touch in this app is that we can also
see the history here of all regex we
generated in the past and actually click
on them to bring them back to the UI of
the app so that's what we're going to
build I hope you're excited let's do it
this video is brought to you by retour
the software builder for any internal
apps or custom software
okay so this is the platform that we are
going to be creating this platform is
built thanks to retool retail is free to
sign up to and will help us create all
these UI components so for example the
button the text inputs the containers as
well as a whole bunch more and allow us
to use apis such as the open AI API that
we are going to be using in order to
generate our regex okay so that's what
we're going to be using we're literally
going to be relying on the knowledge of
open AI whether it's good or not we're
going to find out but essentially we're
just going to be feeding the commands
into here and waiting for it to generate
something so this is what I have
previously built as you will see there
is some text already present or we can
write our own so I can put remove all
letter A from a string and then we can
test it out on a string so if I put
Abacus and then I generate the code that
rejects to help me get rid of any A's
from the string will be generated and
now I can run the code in order to get
the result so as you can see here we
have an array of all the characters from
this string without the letter A we can
of course then you know manipulate this
array join up to make a string you name
it just use some JavaScript on this
array to do what you want with it what
is also cool is that we have the prompt
history right here so let's change this
I'm going to say remove letter C
generate code and then that will
generate the regex and if I run the code
you will see the C has been removed from
that string
and all the characters are now in an
array
so the prompt history is pretty cool if
I now click back on here that will
replace the results we had from that
request okay so a we've got the regex
and then we can run it to get the
results
so this is what we are going to be
building as mentioned we need to sign up
to retool so please just go ahead and
try retail for free I already am using
retail so I'm just going to log in using
my free codecamp account so here we are
this is what you should see when you
sign up okay and now also please go over
to the open AI platform so this is the
URL that you should be at this
platform.openai.com forward slash
playground after you have signed up
okay great so let's carry on the first
thing I'm going to do is just create a
new app and let's go ahead and call this
regex open AI
and create the app
so we have just created an App retail
has given us a table I'm just going to
go ahead and delete that table just so
we can start fresh once here I'm just
going to start dragging and dropping
items so we can do that from the right
panel here the bottom panel so if you
click on here will show you the panel
that we're going to use to write queries
such as communicating with the open AI
API and here you will be able to see the
results so the state of what comes back
from these queries if we wish so I'm
just going to minimize these two as
we're going to work on the UI first
so all I'm going to do is just drag in
first of all some text and I'm going to
change this to say AI regex developer
okay and we can use HTML if we want if
we want to make this an H1 element like
so then we can
so there we go that's something that I
have chosen to do and we can also add
emojis if we want so for example I can
just put a robot Emoji like so
and there we go that is looking cool
the next thing we're going to do is just
use a divider so we can divide
the space
visibly
between the title and what we're going
to be doing below
so actually maybe let's make this a tiny
bit smaller
instead of using the
HTML elements we can also use markdowns
such like this in order to differentiate
between if something is a header or not
what is also used for is that you can
rename these components so I could put
header element just like so in case we
need to pick it out later and then that
will be changed in a much more readable
way for us to work with so that we go
that is looking good the other thing I
want to do is just put a link
so we can search for a link so that's
all I've done and I've dragged it into
here
this linked text I'm going to change to
say open AI playground in case we need
to open up later on
so playground just like so we can also
use icons so if I want to add an End
Icon I can use suffix icon and then I
can just search for something that I
would like to use so I think we should
search for something that resembles us
clicking out and opening a new tab so
for example this icon right here amazing
so we have now just created a link and
that will open up to a specific URL and
that URL is going to be this one right
here so I'm going to copy it and then
I'm going to add an event handler and
this is going to essentially open URL
so I'm going to select go to URL and the
URL I'm just going to place in here so
now if we click on this it will take us
to the open AI API playground wonderful
this is looking good so far
next I'm just going to put in some text
so this is going to tell us what's going
to happen so again I'm just going to
make sure that it's in bold using
markdown language so these two stars and
I'm going to put write me a Java Script
regular expression that dot dot dot and
then I'm just going to put in those two
stars again
so wonderful this is looking great I'm
happy with that I'm just going to drag
that out
okay next I'm just going to put a text
area so a bit bigger than an input and
I'm just going to drag that over like so
and we can choose to either make it
bigger or smaller and we can also choose
to have a label or not so I'm just going
to hide that label in here
once again we can choose to rename it so
I'm going to put regex prompt
just like so and there we go now if I
want to have some default text I can do
so let's go ahead and change our default
value let's go ahead and put remove all
letters a from a string okay so that is
going to be our default text
and we can also add a placeholder if we
wish so if you don't want to have some
default text you can just put a
placeholder in instead so enter a prompt
EG
remove
all letters a from a string so it's up
to you whichever one you want so a
placeholder will look like this
great
I'm just going to move that up a little
bit next I'm going to search for a text
input and I'm just going to drag that
over like so this text input we're
actually going to disable it as we just
wanted to show the generated regex so
let's rename this to generated red jacks
just like so let's label this generated
reject so it's visible to the user and
if there's nothing in here let's just
have a placeholder of create a regex
from a prompt above
okay so that creates a regex from The
Prompt above
let's put disabled as true as we don't
want to interact with it we just want to
read what it says
so let's also put read-only true
and then we will come back to this when
the time is right so that we can
actually put in that expression I'm just
going to create another text input so
let's search for text input because
we're going to have to now have a test
string too so this one we do want to be
able to interact with I'm just going to
move these all up a little bit
let's rename this as regex test
string just like so
let's change the label to be test string
so it's obvious to the user and we can
have a default value sure let's go ahead
and put Abacus so just like so let's
also have a placeholder just in case we
need one so enter a test string dot dot
and I think that looks good I'm just
going to add a button here that won't do
much for now but I'm also going to
rename it so let's learn this button
generate regex
button
as the text I'm going to put generate
code
and as a suffix icon I'm just going to
have a little arrow so once again I'm
just going to find the one that best
represents what we need it to do and
it's probably this one great so there we
go we have a button it won't do much
anymore but that is fine we are just
working on the UI for now
now I'm going to show you how to create
a custom component so I'm just going to
drag that here
and drop it in and we're going to create
a custom code editor so that is what
we're going to do here
so what I'm going to do is just delete
this iframe code and delete the model
here because we're going to start from
scratch
and now for the iPhone code I'm just
going to provide you with some code and
talk you through it okay so what is
happening here is that we are opening up
a script that will talk to code mirror
this is code mirror right here it
essentially allows us to create
different code editors in an iframe and
we can start them up you can essentially
provide a theme so this is something
that we will also do so the first two
scripts are essentially to get code
mirror along with its version and then
in these style tags well we're going to
import the CSS needed to style the code
editor thanks to one of the CSS files
that code mirror provides as well as a
theme so that's what the two Imports are
doing and then we're going to style it
up a little bit in our own way by
providing a border a gray border with a
4 pixel radius so that is what it looks
like at the moment in the next script as
well the JavaScript comes in and we're
essentially writing our own JavaScript
in order to display the text that we
need but when we start feeding in test
strings and prompts and so on so at the
moment we don't have that which is why
initializing is showing okay so that is
showing up because of the code that we
have written here
so please go ahead and take this code
okay it's yours just put it in the
iframe just like I have done because all
we're going to do is have to feed in
data into it through the model input so
to do this well first off I'm actually
just going to create an app state so
let's get rid of this query I'm just
going to delete that and I'm just going
to create a temporary State let's go
ahead and put it in a folder and I have
just renamed It App State and now I'm
just going to add into the App State so
making sure that you're in here a
temporary state so I'm just going to
drag that in like so and let's call this
current regex text
okay so just like that now my current
regex text is going to be that and that
is the rejects that we need in order to
remove all letters a from a string so
that is going to be my initial value
next I'm also going to create a
temporary State called current
test string
it's going to move that in here and the
current test string is going to be
Abacus so just like so
I'm also going to create a temporary
State called
last run index
and again move it in here and I'm just
going to put 0 as a value for this for
now so these are all things that we're
going to use in our model and feed into
the code
I'm also going to have prompt history so
prompt history which will allow us to
save the prompt history on the left hand
side which at the moment is going to be
an empty array
and then we're also going to have reset
index and I'm just going to drag it in
like that and add the value as 0 for now
okay so now that we have all those it's
time to write our model
so I'm going to open up some Kylie bases
I'm going to put the string regex here
and I'm going to now go into the current
reject text and get its value so we're
essentially going into here and getting
this value so that's what we're going to
feed into here so there you go that's
been fed in okay into my code next let's
do the test string so we've got the
regex in here already now we're going to
do the test
string
and that's going to be well we're going
to get the current test string value so
just like that and you will see that
update
next we also need to get the last run
index
and once again we're going to get the
last run index from our temporary
storage and get its value and you will
also see that update
then we need the Run results which was
going to be an empty array because we're
going to populate that
and then we get the reset index
which is just going to be our reset
index
value and that's it that is our model
that we're feeding into the code
great
so this is what it looks like at the
moment
now I'm just going to create a button so
I'm just going to drag in any other
button here
let's change the button of this to run
this time I'm going to prefix an icon
and it's going to be the play icon
so we can even search for it like so I'm
just going to prefix it like that and we
can change the color of this if we wish
let's go ahead and choose the success
color so that's all I've done I'm also
going to create another button that will
allows to reset so there it is let's
change the button name of this to reset
let's also have a prefix icon maybe one
that resembles resetting
so maybe this one like so and then let's
change the color of this so I'm going to
change the color of this to be this
highlight color right here
great
and finally let's have one more text
input so I'm just going to drag that
here we can change the positioning of
the label so we can make it at the top
and then I'm just going to change this
to be regex
matches
we can also rename this to regex
display
and as the default value I'm just going
to put in this code so we're going to
send you the code editor model run
result and if it's a string we simply
show the result otherwise we pass it
through Json stringify okay so that's
what we're going to do and let's also
rename this to code editor
okay as essentially we are looking for
the component of code editor and getting
the model from it
great
as a placeholder for this I'm just going
to put an empty array
and wonderful let's just stretch that
out
and one last thing before we start using
the open AI API is I'm just going to use
one more link right here so I'm just
going to drag that in and I think we
should have some regex help so I'm just
going to use regex
help us the text and let's add a prefix
for this or actually maybe a suffix icon
which again will just take us to a new
page so let's find the icon that will
help us do this and it's this one right
here and wonderful so now we have some
regex help as well we could also align
it to the right if we wish and if we
click on this so let's get an event
handler I want to go to URL and then
just paste in the URL like so so this
will take us to the regular expressions
help on mdn Docs great
so this is all looking good I'm liking
how the UI is looking it's time to now
get the history prompt up and start
working with the open AI API so to
create a sidebar I'm just going to
select the left panel here and let's
create a sidebar so there we go that's
all I have done and now I'm just going
to delete this
so delete that
and let's go ahead and delete this image
as well and now we can drag and drop
items in here so I'm just going to drag
in some text and this is going to say
prompt history just like so so prompt
history let's just add a few more hashes
in here to symbolize a lesser important
title I'm just going to rename this to
sidebar header while we are at it
great next I'm just going to search for
navigation so all I'm going to do is
just drag a navigation like so and let's
call this prompt history enough so just
like that now instead of having this
manual I'm going to map out things onto
here so that's all we're going to do
just make sure that this is turned on
so prompt history value and at the
moment that array is empty but when it's
not that should be filled up okay and
the label for this is going to be the
item itself
so there we go and we don't really want
an image so let's get rid of the logo we
just want some text
wonderful
so now let's get to hooking up the open
AI API so all I'm going to do is Click
resources here
and let's create a new resource we're
going to configure a rest API to do this
next we're going to go to this URL right
here the platform openai.com account API
key and we're going to select a new key
and copy it like so okay so that is my
one right there let's go back to
configuring our rest API and I'm just
going to call this open AI API now we're
going to have to put in a base URL and
that's going to be http
API dot open AI
.com
V1 forward slash don't forget to put an
SDF https now let's go to the headers
and we're just going to add
content
type
right here and we're going to set the
value AS application Json and now we're
going to choose authentication we're
going to go with basic
and as the username we're going to put
Bearer
and we're going to put the openai API
key as the password this will configure
hdb bear authentication for the openai
API and now we're just going to create
the resource
so now let's test it out I'm just going
to go back to here we can shut all these
down and refresh the retool app and
let's write a test query so all I'm
going to do is choose a resource query
I'm going to search for open AI API
let's make this a little bit bigger so
we can see
let's rename this to something else
I'm just going to say this on run and do
generate regex
this is going to be a post request to
completions
from the API
and then here the body is going to be
Json the model we're going to put as
text DaVinci zero zero three then as the
prompt so let's put a prompt in here as
well let's put write me a Java Script
regular expression that removes the
character
a from a string
as a literal without a variable
declaration so essentially what we're
going to be replacing is this from The
Prompt that we have on our UI and all of
it will get sent over to the open AI API
so that is our prompt let's also add a
temperature okay so how accurate we want
it temperature
I'm going to put 0.7
let's have Max tokens
256.
top P one
then we're just going to add a few more
things in here frequency penalty
zero
presence penalty zero as well
and I think that should be it so I'm
just going to save that and let's run it
and there we go so there's our response
that is what comes back to us so the
regex has been generated this is looking
good which means we now can replace that
text with whatever we put in here so
What's this called This is regex prompt
we need to get the value of that so
let's go ahead and write me a regular
expression that removes
character a from a string so let's
remove that and use our Kylie braces so
let's remove that and get our curly
braces so we can pick out the regic
prompt component and get its value so
now whatever you write in here will be
essentially replaced here and then when
we save this and run it it will
essentially create some regex for us
thanks to the open AI API so now let's
actually link this up right so let's do
it so on this button as soon as we click
this button we want to trigger something
we want to add an event handler and it's
going to be to trigger generate regex
that is correct and as loading we could
just have generate regex
is
fetching
and we disable it when generate regex
is
fetching okay so that will be able to
get us the code that we need and let's
link up this button as well so maybe
let's rename this to run button and when
we click on this
we want to just run this script we want
to get the last run index and reset its
value
same for the reset button let's name
this reset
button
and then also I'm going to choose to run
a custom script so run script and here
it is this time we're going to get the
reset index and essentially reset its
value
okay great so now I'm just going to
actually let's maybe not have a
placeholder let's have the default value
and it's also have a default value here
so
remove all letters a from
a script
just so that it's picked up from the
getca
so everything is now hooked up we just
need to write what happens when this is
a success so let's get up this query
again here's the generate regex query
and on success this time so let's add a
success event I'm going to run a
separate script
so here is the code we're getting the
prompt history and if the history does
not include the value we then
essentially add it to the history okay
we add it to the history so it will show
up here and then we update the text
Fields above so this is the code that
you're going to need please pause here
and take all of it
that is what it should look like so
let's save that and try it out so I'm
just going to minimize that and generate
code and great that has updated to AC
after changing it here it's updated here
and let's run it
and the C's have been taken out we get
an array of all the characters without
this C included so that's all I'm gonna
do so that should be fine now
and now I'm just going to add three S's
and generate code and that has changed I
can go a lot more and generate code and
that has changed let's remove all
letters D from a script and generate the
code and that has changed and you will
see all the prompts of the history
showing up as well so now if we run this
amazing well there is no D so that comes
back we get all the characters in an
array let's try removing another letter
let's try and remove the s's generate
code so that has been generated and
let's run it and that indeed works this
is great we have now figured out how to
use openai to build our own regex tool
the last thing I'm going to do is just
go back to the prompt whenever we click
on it so let's do it to do this I'm just
going to get up my right panel and on
each of the items I'm going to
essentially add an event handler
so let's go down to interaction and add
an event handler and I'm going to run
some custom
script and here it is so all we're going
to do is get the prompt history value
and Trigger the generate regex against
will essentially regenerating that regex
so that's all I'm going to do so that
should be fine now so if I click on this
one ta-da that should update this is
looking great and of course we can go to
whichever one we want
wonderful
so this is really it and of course I can
share it I can share with whoever I want
we can invite new users or I could just
go to the app like so and it will show
up on this URL right here for anyone to
use who I share this URL with
amazing this is looking wonderful
so that's it thank you so much for
coding along with me all the necessary
docs and helper docs will be in the
description below so please do check it
out if you need thanks so much again and
I'll see you again soon